hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book two of his work on anger
particularly in chapters 19 and 20.
Seneca is going to examine our
Tendencies towards anger and
irascability in terms of a
outmoded scientific slash medical
understanding that I think many of us
are familiar with and it's interesting
to look at what he says he's not saying
that people are automatically going to
give in to anger but there's certain
factors that could play a role and so
one of these is what we can call
temperament which is rooted in the
nature of our particular bodies and he
begins by saying that an Ardent mind is
by nature most vulnerable to
wrathfulness iracundia right to this
tendency to get angry and Ardent just
means hot fervidos right so he talks
about there being four elements
recognized by people in his time this is
a pretty common theory running all the
way into the Middle Ages and even early
modernity fire water air Earth the
traditional four elements Theory
sometimes people would add a
quintessence or Fifth Element to it but
this is sort of the standard thing
particularly for stoics as he is going
to talk about in a little bit and in
addition to these correlated with these
we have four properties potestates
literally powers or capacities and he's
going to focus a bit more on these than
worrying about the elements and these
are hot
cold dry and moist and the one he's most
interested in is of course hot right and
so this is going to be quite important
he tells us the blending of the elements
produces variations now notice all the
different things that it produces
variations in places
creatures bodies customs
creatures innate Natures incline more in
a given Direction in direct proportion
to the greater force that the
preponderance of a given element
supplies so if you've got a lot of fire
in your body you're going to be a hot
person but particularly if you've got
more of it than other stuff if you're
like perfectly balanced well then you're
right in the middle some people are more
cold some people are more dry some
people are more moist and you can have
combinations of these so you could be
primarily hot but also dry primarily hot
but also moist you're not going to be
primarily hot and cold because those are
opposites to each other just like you're
not going to be primarily dry but also a
little bit moist those are those are
opposed to each other as well and so the
inclinations that we have are quite
important but he also says there's some
areas that are moist and dry and hot and
free rigid right so that's that's quite
interesting there
um
it it implies that geography can have an
effect on us and so he says the same
distinctions are valid for animals and
humans it makes a difference how much
moisture and heat each individual has
within them the element that
predominates in him will determine his
characteristic behaviors so we've got
human beings as
I won't say controlled or completely
determined by the different elements
that are within them but it it steers
them in a certain direction it makes
them more vulnerable you could say to
certain impulses and less to others and
so he goes on and he tells us that
Ardent or hot Natures
right the the natures that Natures of
the soul that are fair vid or or warm
make people irascible
uh you know liable to get angry more
easily than others more vulnerable to
this and so
he goes on and you know he says some of
our sect have it that anger is stirred
in the breast by the boiling of the
blood around the heart and this area
above all is assigned to anger just
because the breast is the warmest place
in the body right now it's you might say
well that's ridiculous you know what
what would blood boiling around the
heart have to do with anger
it's very important to realize that that
was one of the ways that Aristotle
actually defined anger in uh various
places in his work you know looking at
it as a physical phenomena for example
on the soul you know and and uh a few
other places and Seneca says that you
know a lot of people in my school the
stoics accept this as well now why
because the heart as opposed to the
brain
was viewed as the locus of our
Consciousness our feelings and stuff
like that so you know uh anger is is
driven by fire fire is very active and
intransigent it doesn't give in it's
aggressive it moves outward and so we've
got anger is blood boiling around the
heart a very interesting for us physical
metaphor right
so you know if you've got a lot of fire
in the breast as we say then you're
liable to be an angry person what about
if you have other elements within you so
he says that if you're cold you're not
really going to be liable to anger
um why not well because a mixture in
which cold predominates makes a person
timid cold is sluggish and pinched so
you know the good news is if you do have
a cold disposition anger is probably not
a big problem for you there's other
vices that will be a problem and we'll
come back to those in just a bit what if
you're moist
so you know Seneca thinks that you could
be moist and and warm naturally or you
could be at a certain stage in life he
says that um
the anger of people whose makeup is
predominantly moist grows gradually why
they don't have a ready supply of warmth
and it's gained only by movement so it
takes causes coming in you know making
it happen that's why he says the anger
of children and women is more sharp than
Grievous and rather trivial at its onset
but you could be uh adults you know male
and also be moist in this sense or wet
have you know predominance of that and
then your anger just kind of grows
gradually not so much like the hot
nature right what if you're dry on the
other end of the spectrum he says that
the anger of people who have dryness in
them uh is going to be violent and
strong but without increase it doesn't
grow because cold follows upon the heat
which is bound to slack off and who does
he give as an example this old people
old people are difficult and querulous
queerless means and don't don't do that
sort of thing I don't like it you know
the the caricature of the whiny old
person who's being driven with with some
anger and this brings us to a bunch of
factors that play a role so old age
plays a role in this it changes our
nature as our body goes through some
Transformations modifications as we age
it becomes drier less moist and
therefore that modifies the heat he also
talks about exhaustion and bloodletting
right so
it was a not just a medieval thing this
is an ancient thing practiced by doctors
if they thought you had too much blood
in you it would cut your vein and let
some of it drain on then you'd be pretty
worn out afterwards uh you know because
you're you're missing some of what you
need to circulate all the oxygen in your
your system so that or being exhausted
he'll talk a little bit later about
making children engage in exercise not
to the point where they're totally worn
out but enough to like you know get some
of that energy out of their system if
they do get completely worn out uh maybe
they're going to be less angry or if
they do get angry it'll be kind of a
weak anger he also talks about thirst
and starvation
uh he says people wasting away from
thirst and starvation are in the same
situation as are those whose bodies lack
a full supply of blood and are weak from
malnutrition so these are things that
can get in the way of anger as well and
then we come to the things that can
increase the anger right physically and
the one thing that he singles out the
most wine right now wine is the most
common form of alcohol you're going to
find in the ancient Mediterranean world
I mean if he was further north maybe he
would have said beer or ale or something
like that or if he was somewhere else it
would be a different kind of intoxicant
and Seneca thinks that and he's not the
only person he brings up Plato here as
well that wine tends to make us hotter
right wine Kindles bouts of anger
because it increases heat some drunks
come to a boil right and then he says
you know it's also like people who've
been wounded according to the
individual's nature Wine Works in kind
of the same way and then he has a very
funny observation here which again do we
should we take this seriously
some people who have flushed complexions
and Blondes also are most disposed to
anger they have the coloring that other
people usually acquire when they're
angry so they they're already like on
the way to that so you know we could
think about people getting drunk and
getting flushed as as well
and you know disease or injury could
make us less liable to anger but
actually Seneca includes it in
conditions that
um you know nature inclined some people
to anger other factors that arise can
have the same effect disease or physical
injury
toil extended periods without sleep
troubled nights right all of those
irritants all those things can make us
more liable to getting angry to
expressing our anger to acting on the
anger they in certain ways incapacitate
us right and then the last one that he
talks about that I think is particularly
interesting
desire or love right and he's using two
words here that convey so love is you
know physical love looking to uh get
engaged get entangled with somebody uh
people who are in love are you know more
stirred up you could say but desire is a
broader category does it desiderium
right this means desire not just for say
sex or attention but it could be for
money could be for Prestige or position
those who are already engaged in a path
like that are more likely to
get hot as we say right
now he says all of these factors are
first causes another big influence is
habit so obviously it's not as if this
is determining us entirely he says
nature is difficult to change but you
know we can do something so he says it
would be useful to know art and nature
should be kept from wine which Plato
thinks should be denied to Children
basing his prohibition on the ground
fire shouldn't be aroused with fire they
shouldn't even be filled with food their
bodies will become swollen and their
minds will become bloated right so he
goes on and I mentioned we would talk
about other vices
so he tells us those Natures that are
moisture or drier or cold aren't really
at risk for anger but you have to be
beware of less spirited vices like being
panicky cross-grained hopeless
suspicious these uh Natures must be
soothed cherished and roused to
happiness some remedies must be used
against anger others against gloominess
and we have to think about what kind of
situation what kind of temperament we're
dealing with and then we can find the
appropriate remedies to you know he's
thinking primarily about children but we
could apply this to everybody else and
to ourselves if we know that we are
naturally irritable people maybe we can
try to avoid the sorts of things that
get us riled up you know if we know that
we do have problems with wine or other
intoxicants getting us more you know in
a a situation more liable to anger we
can avoid that sort of thing now again
to point this out one more time I don't
know anybody at present who actually
believes in the Four Element Theory uh I
mean there are some people who believe
in temperaments but they don't really
base it on this physical science or
medicine anymore
but it's interesting to see what Seneca
has to say given that he actually does
buy into this and that he thinks that
some people are going to have greater
struggles with anger than others because
of their physical makeup